[Music]  here in rangiora we've been discussing  the concept  of a civic precept now that involves the  expansion of the  rangiora library here and the main  council building  this would allow the library to cater  for our growing population  and would enable the creation of  community spaces  for things like art displays or even a  museum  the upgrade would also better  accommodate staff currently spread  across  six different buildings in rangiora the  council's preference  is to put this project on hold until  2028  now that's going to help keep debt and  rates down  in the short term other options include  accelerating the funding and  construction of the combined civic  precinct building  or shelving the project altogether  visit waimakariri.govt dot nz  forward slash let's talk to take a look  at the options  and to have your savings